[Music]
welcome to winners you guys get what you
need I'm gonna gather some last minute
for business Oh provisions just as
they're missing doesn't say they're dead
do you ever hear someone going missing
in the woods showing up two months later
roasting marshmallows
this is it we shouldn't be here just
throw up a few tents all the do being
call it a night
there's no house for miles it's just
chill
[Applause]
I scare you huh don't tell a lot of
people is all right with your family so
that's different
I've been seeing these things going on
ain't sure what they want but a nice
yesterday everything is normal and today
we got aliens I think there's a
connection between hallucinogenic drugs
and aliens you could tap in if you were
really open to it they come through this
chemical pathway like I take no chances
that's it I ain't taking no chances yeah
how about this we're gonna perform a
little brain surgery
[Applause]
[Applause]
that's going to leave a mark
there's so many other things with all
over the place you can't run
[Applause]
[Music]
you